if someone came up to you and said
hollywood is making a movie about a
woman that falls in love with a zombie
you'd probably be like get the [ __ ] out
of here but then you'd be upset at
yourself for saying that why because
warm bodies is awesome it's got a lot of
things going on it's really funny super
romantic scary at times but mostly it's
just one damn good entertaining film the
directing and writing i imagine had a
lot of challenges with having to balance
many different tones and layers but oh
man do they succeed the production
design is fantastico this cinematography
is excellent the soundtrack enhances the
storytelling experience but most
importantly the acting by nicholas holt
the character r and teressa palmer the
hot [ __ ] julie are excellent it's this
great acting pair and their chemistry
that really sells the movie you might
not laugh throughout but more likely you
will just have one big [ __ ]
smile all in all i gotta say warm bodies
got it super right
you